Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
My name is Dylan Flanagan. Although you may
know me from across the Internet as Rawkode.
Today is a solo hands on expedition
as I explore a product called Spin from
a company called Fermion.
Full disclosure, I have been doing some work
for Fermion recently,
helping them produce content to show the world
how cool WebAssembly could be. And we're gonna
run through a few of those examples that
I've been working on today, as well as
cover the basics about what Spin is, what
Fermion are trying to achieve, and of course,
writing some code.
Well, you know, I mean, we rely on
Copilot to do most of the heavy lifting.
So if you wanna keep me company, feel
free to say hello in the comment section.
Let me know if you have any questions
about Fermion,
Spin, or WebAssembly as we run through today's
exercises.
What I will do is since I'm wearing
a custard Kubernetes t shirt and the first
kind of question came in
during the holding screen.
Let's tackle that. So Russell says that he
is interested to hear what I think
about Spin as he's heard it is designed
for Nomads rather than Kubernetes.
So I don't have a link prepared now,
but the first piece of content I did
with Fermion was an interview with the two
co founders. So that's Rado, the CTO,
and Matt, the CEO.
They're both responsible for
or at least they were contributors and maybe
even
creators. I can't remember the exact specifics. Think
they were the creators and the maintainers and
the contributors
of a pro project called Crustlet, which was
a fake kubelet to allow you to run
WebAssembly workloads in Kubernetes.
This is a project I've actually covered multiple
times, maybe not on this channel directly, but
there may have been an episode or a
hack, but I have definitely played with it
and talked about it when I were to
Equinix
and
on my Discord channel once or twice. So
running WebAssembly
to me has always been interesting and doing
it in Kubernetes means that I can transfer
a lot of that knowledge and experience that
I already have. And, of course, I can
run workloads side by side. Like, there's no
reason I can't run container based workloads next
to web assembly workloads, next to virtual machine
workloads. And Kubernetes does give us a control
plane that is extensible enough to allow us
to do that.
Looking back to what I said about the
first piece of content I did to Fairbeam
was an interview with the two founders as
that one of the things that they shared
was that they really pushed
Trustlet, and it took a lot of effort
to get a system that kinda worked.
But what they found is they weren't really
getting the characteristics that they expected from pushing
that, you know, an alternative runtime into Kubernetes
that doesn't really conform to the CRI spec.
The container resource interface spec is is there
to run containers. You can run other things,
but Kubernetes and, you know, the and the
CRI make a lot of
assumptions about there always being a process within
namespaces.
And WebAssembly doesn't work that way. It's got
its own sandbox,
which is provided by
WasmTime
or
Node. Js isolates or whatever that runtime is
gonna be.
So it doesn't even have any concept of
of POSIX. Now while there's work with the
Wazi specification, it's gonna bring that to WebAssembly,
at least server side WebAssembly.
These are things that are being added through
something called the capability model,
which allows you to extend
the WebAssembly sandbox with new features by providing
the ability to either gRPC or HTTP call
out to alternative systems, which have again more
constraints in place. So
what they said in there, and I will
send the link to this interview. I'll stick
it into the show notes.
You just go to youtube.com
and search for Fermion, it's on their official
channel. It was the most recent video I
believe.
It's a really interesting interview, but I keep
it off topic. But the the thing that
really trying to drive home about why they
went with Nomad rather than continuing, you know,
they've got a lot of experience in Kubernetes
too. These are people that work on the
Azure cloud team pushing Kubernetes.
They are responsible for Helm. They're responsible for
Brigade.
They're responsible for Crustlet. Kubernetes was their bread
and butter. However, what they said was they
pushed it as far as they could get
it.
And the startup times for containers are slow.
If you need to run a new container,
you're talking hundreds of milliseconds,
potentially seconds depending on whether,
you know, network image is there, IP address
space, a whole bunch of other things.
Things they don't really need to worry about
with WebAssembly.
And one of the things that they kind
of affirmed in our interview was that Nomad
is built to run different types of workloads.
It runs containers,
but it can also run the JVM.
And, actually,
the JVM is much more compatible
as a runtime to WebAssembly than it is
to containers.
So
what they what they said in this I'm
just gonna kinda reveal the whole interview now
instead of making you go watch it. But
what they shared there is that with Nomad,
they have the ability to schedule new workloads
and have almost sub millisecond
initialization,
bootstrap, and start
of web assembly workloads on Nomad. Something that
just wasn't possible on Kubernetes.
A strong
proportion of our interview,
Matt and Raghu focus on WebAssembly is not
a all end situation.
You know, while we may have a future
where entire companies and applications are built on
WebAssembly,
they really see them as complementary
technologies. Like, you will always need containers. You
will still need VMs. We still need VMs
today even though we have containers.
So
web assembly is there to enrich and augment
those container based and virtual machine based or
or even bare metal workloads if that's how
you're operating.
But give us a development experience that works
locally and remotely just the same. And that's
really what I wanna show today is I
play with Spin and explore it. So
that was that a bit of a divergence
just to answer that first question, but I
hope that context, the history, that flavor is
useful to you. Russell, if you have any
more questions drop them straight into the chat.
I see we have a question from Moz
as well. So thank you for joining us,
Moz too.
The first time I saw WebAssembly when I
was trying to learn how to write on
voice filters using TinyGo.
That's the Spin project use TinyGo or something
else.
Excuse me. Okay. So spin
allows you to write
and develop micro services in almost any language.
And we'll cover a few of the constraints
there today.
If you write your spin application using their
Go SDK, it does use tiny go. Yes.
It also supports rust out of the box
and for that you're just using standard rust
with,
you know, was a target.
And
yeah, really rust makes it really really easy.
Put on to I go block someone in
the comment.
It's not quite made it onto live yet.
I could just see here.
I don't have the ability to block from
here.
Oh, they've built I think YouTube got them.
Alright. Thank you YouTube automation.
So, yeah. It uses technical Rust just uses
Rust and then any language that really compels
them to web assembly can be used.
You won't have access to the same abstractions
provided by Spin, but you can still do
a lot of things.
What I really loved about Spin is that
different modules can be written in different languages,
you can still just consume them because once
you've produced that artifact that target that small
wasm dot file, you just ship it to
OCI or somewhere else that can be consumed.
And I don't know if you're familiar, but
Docker desktop made a big announcement
two weeks ago.
That would be the November for anyone not
watching his life where they said that actually
now you can use Docker pull commands to
pull down WebAssembly boundaries from OCI registries.
And Docker Hub now supports OCI artifacts. So
all these things are coming together. And then
the special sauce from Docker is actually
you can run containers and WebAssembly side by
side. So I missed this in an announcement,
but someone pointed out to me just earlier
in the week. But you can write a
Docker Compose file that runs a bunch of
containers as you always have.
However, now one of those services could be
a Wasm binary,
And it just runs side by side, does
the thing, and communicate with the other services.
And I think that's pretty special. And I
I really I'm really excited now. And I
I mean, I've always been excited about WebAssembly.
If you're in my Discord server, you'll you'll
see many chats about WebAssembly and the things
that we want to do with it, like
a trial project and other things. But really
interesting being able to have a Docker Compose
file that we know we're comfortable with, we've
used before, we've been using for years
and just stick a WebAssembly service into there.
And that's something I definitely will be exploring
more on the channel and they come in
days, weeks, or months.
So, Mozz, yes. A lot of way of
saying tiny go is what it uses there.
Russell's saying thank you for the answer. My
pleasure.
And then Russell is saying, I wonder if
they will tell me team up with Nova.
Yeah. That project is really cool.
I'm
not sure. I've never said it out loud
before,
but definitely, you know, we're we're gonna see
more
innovation in this space with cohesive multi runtime
component things happening side by side.
And I think that's really interesting. So
let's let's get started. I don't expect to
do ten to fifteen minutes of questions, but
really,
really interesting ones. So thank you both for
answering
asking.
I had fun answering. And if anyone has
anything else, drop it straight into the comments.
I always love to kinda sit and talk.
What I'm gonna do now
is share my screen.
And
I'm gonna pull down our website as well
while I'm at it.
There we go.
So this is the the fermion website at
fermion.com.
We're gonna be taking a look at Spin
today, which is their web assembly framework. It
allows you to build web assembly applications and
provides all the craft, the boilerplate, the glue.
You just focus on that small little bit
of code that makes up your domain logic.
This is the promise that we got
from Lambda and serverless functions and fast,
but I've never really seen that backed up
with a strong developer experience like we're gonna
see with Spin today.
And this is
best developer experience about local and ship into
production is why I'm so interested in this
space.
So as we can see here, it is
a
framework for building event driven microservice applications with
web assembly component.
Now this day event driven and that is
very important because
the spin application,
and this comes back to the reason of
using Nomad. The Spin application is not just
a service that runs perpetually
and consistently.
A Spin application
responds
to either a Redis queue, something an end
to a Redis queue, or an HTTP request.
And, looking back to the interview that I
had, why Radu was so excited about this
model is that they can spin up a
WebAssembly module in under a millisecond, which means
they provide the HTTP interface, and they provide
the Redis interface.
And if you have either of those, and
under a millisecond, they can launch an entirely
new WebAssembly instance of the application,
pass in the request, the response, shut it
down, clean it up, garbage collect, and it's
just done.
This is really cool.
With FaaS built on top of containers, we've
always had to struggle and fight with the
cold start problem.
And the cold start problem again comes back
to it takes hundreds of milliseconds to start
a container.
So I either run
these serverless functions
on an endless loop and I scale them
to what I need and I reuse connections
whenever possible. Again, violating this
CGI model that we're trying to get to
a serverless where everything is handled by its
own
instant.
If that's there to solve that cold start
problem. And with WebAssembly, that goes away because
the runtime is just that fast. Then you
use this wasm time under the hood,
which is a WebAssembly runtime written in Rust.
So I've already installed Spin. The instructions are
here.
As far as the structure of a Spin
application goes, we do have a dot TOML,
and then we just have some Rust code.
And look at this handler. How nice is
this? Now I'm a huge fan of Rust.
I'm always talking about Rust,
But this is just cool because there's a
few things here that are very rusty.
Excuse me. I've got terrible cough today.
First, we have this macro that surrounds our
function.
Let's come back to that in a moment
and kinda understand what Rust is doing there.
But our function again has a very simple
interface
as well. It receives a request that returns
a result response.
Don't worry about the result if you're not
from the Rust ecosystem, it's just an okay
triple,
but it just takes a request and spits
out a response.
You know? HTTP in, HTTP out.
Then ignoring the okay, which is just again
our okay triple,
We just say here, wanna return an HTTP
response, Rust provides a builder for this. We
set the status to 200 and we return
hello fermion as a string. We use n
two just to cast it into an actual
string object instead of a Rust
more primitive string object regardless, you're gonna note
it. And then the question mark is just
to do some basic error handling in case
any of that fails, which it really shouldn't
in this case.
So we're only focusing on what we need
to relay to the user.
This macro is what provides all the boilerplate.
This is the procedural macro and injects all
the code into this function to make everything
work and make sure that the request and
response are handled appropriately.
Can't don't need to do anything. When we
have rust and the ability to do the
level of meta programming where we use macros
to define boilerplate and keep it out of
our domain logic applications, we get a very
clean interface to build application.
And our microservices
and the spin environment
are
many of these.
Every issue to be endpoint potentially
that we want to handle has an issue
to be component function.
We can register the path for all of
these functions
and the spin dot toml and away we
go.
The manifest itself for the spend dot toml
just needs a spend version, a name, and
then we can set up the trigger. So
the trigger at the moment can be HTTP
and Redis.
They are working on more support and I'm
pushing for some cron style scheduling so I
can do some weird and cool stuff as
well. And you can set a base if
you're gonna can, you know, if you wanna
compound
multiple spin applications together, they all have a
different base, but then they all have sub
pass within that, you know, the the architecture,
the flexibility, whatever you need to do, you
can really do.
From there, we specify the component and the
trigger and away we go.
Shouldn't talk so much when I have a
cough. This is why I have guests so
that I can sit in silence for a
little bit.
Alright. So that's gonna be the basics. If
we take a look at the language support,
we've got the Rust one which we kinda
covered. The only thing you really need to
do is Rust up at a target for
WASM 32 Wazi.
This is all you need to compile any
Rust program to VASI and to VASI spec.
It works really nice.
You can see the exact same code from
here, only this time we have to use
statements to show that we are pulling on
the Spin SDK, which provides the HTTP component
macro
and the request and the response types that
we are using within our application.
If we pop over to go, things are
a little bit similar.
Yep. Here we go. We pull in the
SDK and the go away way. We have
an edit function and a main function.
So this is just setting up. So guess
it's the
yeah. This is our actual
response and then the main would have the
boilerplate that you would need to handle it.
I wonder if that could be done with
go generate. I've not actually played with the
go SDK a whole
lot
because whenever I see Rust is available, I
generally just go straight for Rust.
The only time I don't go straight for
Rust would be if there was a TypeScript
SDK and you can't do spin applications and
TypeScript,
but I don't think the SDK is there
with the abstractions to make things simpler.
As far as other languages, they do have
a whole bunch of examples.
Where's the link?
You know what, I am just gonna
go get hub, fermions,
then
there's a examples directory,
I'm sure. There we go.
And here we can see if we wanna
take a look at watch.
Oh, no. That is just a rust and
things.
It shows there's a green example somewhere.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. And templates then.
If you wanna use green,
then we can take a look at the
file.
We just do print, hello world, and that's
enough. If we wanna do something with Zig,
which is another really cool language that's coming
out in this kind of systems programming space,
And we can take a look at this
example here.
So all we're doing is we don't have
the SDK here
to mimic
the
response and request obstructions provided by Rust about
the the Go SDKs. However,
if we think about what a web server
is actually doing,
which is parsing a string that comes in,
which is an HTTP protocol string, which is
mostly text based unless it's it's not semantics.
I'm not going to right now. And then
we spent the text back out. So here
we're just saying here's the content header, here's
the hello world, and let it handle the
rest. So you can kinda do whatever you
want as long as your language does support
it, but it's probably best to stick to
the SDKs.
And I do think more SDKs will be
added into course.
And that's just our Swift example.
Nice.
Alright.
We got another question
from Russell.
Okay.
Is it either to have lots of functions
on one spin app rather than having lots
of spin apps? No. I don't think so.
That was just me yapping my mouth too
much. I would probably just have a spin
application for each endpoint because it's so easy
to do.
And then a mono repo environment where you
can share a
whole bunch of type descriptors whatever language they
happen to be, whether that
whether it's generating from Probus or JSON Schema
or whatever, I would just go down that
approach. Spin applications are so lightweight, They're very
easy to develop. I've I'd wanna be able
to test them
in a very easy manner, and I would
just have dozens
of spin applications
rather than lots of functions within a single
spin application.
It just means that you spin application is
gonna get us on different prefix
potentially,
but, yeah, that's fine.
Alright. So let's
just see the, you know, I I kinda
said at the start here, the developer experience
is what's really pushing me to do more
of a spin. So let's take a look
at that. We can run spin new.
Let me find
a bit bigger.
We see all the templates from the repository.
Now we've already looked at a few of
these.
So let's just say we're gonna do
we actually did look oh, we never looked
at c because why would you?
So we can just do h t p
c. You
can do it with spin new and then
just hit return or you can do
spin new and then the template name. Here,
I'll just say example c spin.
We do some stuff.
Get a directory.
We have our spend dot TOML.
So this is just the spin version, sets
up the offers and description, the h t
p trigger with base, and then here is
the component.
So we're gonna compile our c application to
provide something called main dot wasm.
We set up the more trigger stuff. Waggy
is a
is a predecessor
to the Fermion platform,
but Spin and the Fermion platform can still
run Waggy application just fine because the CGI
interface has not really changed that much.
And then we describe the command used to
build it. So again, any
language that can compile to WebAssembly, you can
set a component build command like so. And
here we're using Zig to actually compile the
c to web assembly, which is a cool
new trick. And we get the main dot
wasm and it works.
But that's
pretty boring. So I wanna run through something
that I have in playing with.
So
on the Fermion
documentation,
one directory too high. So let's go up.
Because there's more to this project than the
spin up. On the Fairmain documentation,
they run you through both my URL shortener.
And the URL shortener only accepts static routes.
And what I mean by that is it
only responds
to requests
with roots that are hard coded. The slash
hello
returns to here. And that's fine,
but
being very selfish, I have a use case
where I need
very
static length. Yes. But I also wanna be
able to use an API to programmatically create
links.
And I thought, well, why can't I do
this with Spin?
So that's what we're gonna take a look
at.
So the first thing I did because I
like to over engineer everything that I do
is I set up a Prisma project.
In fact, I probably shouldn't do it that
way. Should change the font size.
I was actually coding for a change, so
my settings are less
livestream ready.
I set up a Prisma because I love
Prisma. Prisma allows me to describe
my database tables and it manages all the
migrations for me, applies them to the remote
clusters.
This is set up to use a local
post res right now. However, I did experiment
with Prisma against CockroachDB,
and it just worked. So
we can
use Prisma to speak to our database.
We describe our models,
and it manages the migrations for us. If
I pop open the migrations folder,
we have an SQL statement that says, hey.
We're gonna create this redirect table with these
fields. And every time I change my Prisma
dot schema, I can have it generate a
new migration where it calculates what has changed
and then always has to kind of upscale
and modify your
remote database schema, thingy, cluster, postgres,
cockroach, whatever, to be the current version.
What What I've also been experiment with and
I haven't got working yet, but I'm gonna
keep hacking on this, is Prisma comes with
a concept of a generator.
And here, we're actually saying that we're gonna
just use the provider, which is a command.
We're gonna use a cargo command called Prisma,
which is actually an alias
to run a
main dot r s here, which is a
Prisma client CLI.
So there is
no. That's the generic code.
So
this generator is gonna generate a Rust client
to speak to our postgres database or our
cockroach DB cloud database.
I've had some problems getting it to compile
to the was a spec or to a
was a target
and that's because the Rust client is using
some features of Tokyo that aren't compatible yet
with the Wazi compilation target.
I think there's other ways to go around
this, but it's gonna require a little bit
more time and effort, but I'm gonna keep
working on it and hopefully I can share
some updates in the coming days and weeks.
But we can generate a client. So if
we pop open this Prisma.rs,
what we have here
is a bespoke generated
client in Rust to speak to my database
with that kind of
not like an active record model, but very
similar. It gives you the ability to find
things very quickly. It gives you the ability
to do upsets and inserts and deletes.
You just got a very good interface to
working with your cluster.
Here I can see, you know, equals or
maybe order something or is it in a
vector or is it not in a vector?
Is it less than? Exactly. This
functional based approach to communicate in a query
in a database is very nice. So hopefully
I get it working.
However,
I can run
back to my CLI,
Docker compose up first because I'm gonna need
a database.
And this is the very standard Docker compose
file. There's no web assembly or enough and
then that's the moment. This is just let's
run Postgres.
It's the most recent version, very secure password,
and I expose the port locally.
That's it.
Excuse me. I also have beekeeper,
which is a
GUI client.
Let's pick the databases.
And what I'm gonna do, if you can
see I already have one fake URL here,
is I can just delete all of this.
So I'll do it from
here. Oh, maybe I can.
Docker
compose
then dash v. This will delete everything and
then we'll spin it back up.
This should clear any persistence, remove all the
databases, and we should start from a clean
state just because actually, don't know how to
delete from beekeeper.
I come back here, password.
We now have
no
public and no read write table.
Perfect.
So from here, I can run PNPX
Prisma migrate dev. That just means run my
migrations against my dev environment, which is the
local postgres.
It's executed.
And if we jump back over to beekeeper
and we hit refresh
and we hit refresh,
Database is now in sync. Don't lie to
me.
Alright. Maybe the refresh button doesn't work.
Let's try one more time.
Hey. Yeah. Don't know why the ref oh,
there's another refresh. That refresh is the alright.
See, I don't use beekeeper much,
but it is a nice special way to
see this schema. So now we have a
reader rest table, which is empty.
So let's just add one.
And to do this, I do need an
ISO 8,601
timestamp because I haven't
set up a default
default value on the created and updated that
schemas, although I really should.
I'm just using UTC time dot now
where I'm gonna say, okay, fake. It could
be my livestream,
which is gonna redirect to Twitter.comRawkode.
I can see here we wanna do a
three zero one and I'm gonna paste in
my ISO a six zero one string and
hit apply.
Now we have one entry as part of
our dynamic URL shortener in which case that
the static words do not match, which I'll
show you in just a moment. Go look
up something and the postgres database and do
a dynamic written to there.
So does I need to use Prisma here?
No.
Is it nice and cool?
I mean, I think so.
What a couple more things about Prisma. There's
lots of generators. So if you wanna generate
Rust types, GraphQL schemas, anything like that, there's
probably a generator. You just add a little
bit of code. This becomes your your your
source of truth for what your models look
like, and then everything else gets generated off
the back of it. And I really wanna
be able to use this together with my
spin application.
Excuse me. Okay. So from here, we have
our spin application.
Here's my spin dot toml. So this is
my Rawkode Academy short links project, which hopefully
I'll get working and deployed very soon on
Fermion Cloud. I'll show you that in a
moment.
And we can see here, it got a
little bit of boilerplate to point it to
the target because I'm using cargo workspaces. This
has to go up a direction before we
go into target.
And then we just specify the build command,
which is just a cargo build target release.
Nice and simple, nothing
too strenuous about putting us together and if
you use one of their templates, it does
it all for you. You don't need to
worry about it.
From here, we have our lib. Rs. So
much like we've seen in the documentation, we're
gonna pull in the Spin SDK, which provides
request response and issue the component.
They also provide some other components, one of
them being the ability to speak to Redis
and the other one being the ability to
speak to Postgres. So we're pulling in this
p g library
so that we can send queries to Postgres.
We have our procedural macro that does all
the glue for us with this application.
We have our function to use as our
entry point,
and I've got some really crappy debugging on
here, which is the print line path, which
just tells me the path for each request
that comes out to the system.
Next, we do a match.
So I'm saying, okay. Let's just look at
what the path is.
And these two here are my static routes.
I can see
yeah. Why not Copilot? Let's do GitHub. What's
the name about the name?
Trust your thing here and we just do
a default redirect for that too. So
what is default redirect?
Well, let's copy it and do
redirect GitHub.
And instead of going to the Rawkode Academy
website, we're gonna go to github.com,
Rawkode
Academy.
And then
we'll change our static rules to be redirect
GitHub.
Now, of course, this is
probably not idiomatic Rust.
Would I create a redirect GitHub? No. I'd
probably just have a redirect static function that
takes a string
where I pass in the URL, probably a
bit cleaner, but just for the sake of
moving on with today's demo, we're not gonna
bother about that.
But what I wanted you to take away
is that we can add to this match
statement all the static paths that we want.
Any URLs that we always want to be
shortened in a particular way regardless of what's
in the dynamic configuration, which requires a database.
We wanna respond really fast and we put
them here. But of course we do it
in we don't.
Of course, we likely want dynamic.
So our last part of this match statement
says, okay. Whatever the other value is, let's
just call it path.
And when we get a path, we're gonna
do some more horrible debugging, which is the
exact same debug as the bottom. I'm actually
just gonna remove that.
I'm gonna trim the slash off of it
to make the match a little bit cleaner.
You know, we don't in our database
want this live to be slash live, we
just want it to be live.
So we'll just trim it off. So if
the string starts with a slash,
disappear.
Then we have a redirect lookup command. So
this is the function that goes and speaks
to postgres.
We pass in the trimmed path and whatever
it returned is what we finish with in
our function.
The fact that there's no colon here or
semicolon
just means that this is a return value
to the match and because the match doesn't
have a semicolon, this is just Rust logic
here. This is the last expression within the
function and it will be returned as our
response.
So let's pop down to redirect lookup.
Excuse me.
Now we
have a hard coded string here.
This is very crappy.
I get it.
Currently,
there's not
a great way to deploy
secrets to Fermion Cloud. However, they are working
on it.
So
just because that's not really there's no primitives
yet. There's some things in config I don't
wanna dive into just now. I'm gonna do
more on that next week.
But let's just get this example working. Let's
have hard code it and it'll be fine.
That was my logic. I hope that makes
sense and I'm gonna skip over it for
the rest of the session.
Then we configure our SQL statement. So how
do we find
a short link within our database? Well, we
select long. The only value we actually care
about is long and I probably should
Let's fix my code and pull back the
status code
since we have that in beekeeper.
Redirect code. Sorry.
Redirect
code.
From the redirect table where short,
so that is this key here
equals
and we're using
parameterized
SQL statements here, so that we're not vulnerable
to SQL or SQL injection attack.
And then we use the postgres
helper provided by the
Spin SDK
to query at the address, which we define
above the statement,
which is our SQL
and then any parameters. Now because we have
a dollar 1,
we need exactly one parameter here.
So we just use the Spin SDK to
say this is a string type
and then we pass on the path.
If there's an error, we map over there
and return that there was an error executing
the query.
Although we're assuming that it's going to just
work because it's a very simple
query.
Don't expect anything to go wrong.
We have one edge case or not really
an edge case. We have one case
where what if we don't have a URL
and a database for that? So for that,
we return a HTTP response builder status code
404.
Hopefully, filters by. Now
if we get past that point, we know
that we have at least one response.
Now at our schema, we actually do specify
that our short is an ID. This will
make it unique. I wonder if we can
see that in Beekeeper.
Structure,
primary key.
Oh, create that. Those have a default value.
Okay. It's just update that.
If we go to indexes, yep, we have
our unique primary key here. So we actually
can,
hopefully
be in a position where we can have
two short codes that match. However,
I just baked the end of the code.
So we always pull out zero base because
we have that guarantee from a database. That
we're never gonna have a one. We don't
need to do anything smart. We're just gonna
take the first one. We do rules that
rules get one at zero, unwrap it, get
the index again to get the first column
which is our link. We can actually get
all of this back and use the redirect
code.
If I'm feeling brave and we have enough
time after we do the DX workflow stuff,
maybe we'll do that.
If this is a string, we return it
and if so we do a redirect to
the location.
And then this is just a little bit
of boilerplate that is needed for working with
the
PG
spend SDK. I grab that straight from the
docs.
I'm just gonna trust that does what it
does. Trust that it does what it does.
It's just guaranteeing that that or trying to
guarantee that if we get column back and
we say that we want a string that
it is going to be a string and
not some other type.
Now
it's not a lot of code, 70 lines
of code. Most of that
could be cleaned up. I don't need redirect
get hub for a start which takes away
nearly 10 lines of code
and our lookup could be cleaned up as
well, but we're doing, you know, multiple lines
to kinda make it fluent and easy to
follow.
So let's jump over to the terminal.
We generated our migration. We run our database.
Now we can run spend build.
Oh, and the spend directory.
This will compile our Rust application,
and we will get our Wasm target.
If I do target,
release
oh,
no. Where's the
And here's somewhere. Oh, wasm
release.
And we have our short links dot wasm
file here.
We've successfully taken our Rust code, compiled it
down to web assembly.
And now we can run spin up.
Now, it's very fast.
And if I if I run spin up
again,
almost instantaneous.
We could probably use hyperfine
if this exit, which it doesn't.
But that would tell us it started
insanely fast.
We get a web server on logos 3,000
and it tells us the available routes. So
if we were to configure spend to do
multiple endpoints which you can, they would be
listed here.
But what I could do here is say
curl
on just a slash.
And I'll do that one more time without
the slash to both match to the same.
You get a three zero one to the
Rawkode Academy
and
a three zero one to the Rawkode Academy.
Let's see if they run hyperfane on this.
And I'll need to do
Yeah. We're getting our response time over HTTP.
Remember, even though it's local host so it's,
you know, we can know PEG related to
anything like that. But
this application is responding
with a deviation of about two milliseconds and
eight milliseconds.
So we're seeing responses anywhere from five point
six milliseconds.
Well, I should have been up to 19,
but, you know, the meantime is within two
milliseconds of 8.4. So
and roughly eight milliseconds we're getting a response
over 241
runs. This is on a local machine
and it's over a URL that hasn't had
in the database and a few other bits
of pieces. It's still kinda cool and very
very fast.
If we do curl
and we do blah, blah, blah, we're
gonna get an error.
Well, there's no complain about my redirect code.
And that's because
I was feeling too brave.
Let remove it.
And we just do a spin build and
I'm just gonna run a spin up.
Let's try that one more time. There we
go. We get our 404.
So what if we run this under hyperfade?
Remember this one does have a database lookup
because
it's
not doing a static match and then it
does have to speak to postgres to see
if there is any match that's still failing
and returning no rows.
And we can see we're getting a meantime
of about twenty five milliseconds.
Actually, a bit slower than I was expecting,
but still insanely fast for what is actually
happening here. So HTTP request, pick the database,
better response.
Not too shabby.
And this is that postgres running in a
local container on my machine, not optimized or
tuned or anything like that. So these numbers
are really, really cool. And again, pushing why
I am excited about assembly.
Let's make this work with our dynamic
link, which was live.
And we'll see here that we got a
three zero one going to twitter.com/Rawkode.
Well, I think this is
pretty cool, pretty neat.
Now for the eagle eyed amongst you,
there's one gotcha
that I kinda had to work out. And
and by work out, I mean, I just
have to run like a spin up dash
dash help. But my log output
that we have
on the URL match here
is nowhere to be seen.
So the way that we fix that is
to run a follow all on the spin
up command.
And now when we run our curl,
we see our path output here.
So as you
are working on your spin application locally, which
I assume you will be,
we can run
follow all to get logs to our local
terminal. And that's just makes your debugging
a lot easier. And you can see even
with the database, we're still getting twenty five
millisecond response time.
So what's that dev workflow again looks like
just to confirm.
Well,
we modify our code.
We run
spin build,
spin up,
and we run curl
to GitHub
too.
And we got our 240
odd responses.
this time. There we go. Static links in
eight milliseconds. That is pretty sweet.
So that's
the demo.
I like the dev experience.
I like the simplicity of the functions. We're
relying on Rust's procedural macros to mean that
I only write the code that I care
about.
I like that they provide libraries for speaking
to postgres and Redis. I wanna do more
with that. I'm really eager for them to
do some sort of
secrets management because
really what I wanna do is after I've
done my my spend build and spills up
spend up,
is we have the access to a spend
deployment,
and we just run this. And we get
a link back
with a production URL
for all of our traffic.
But here,
I have a fermion. App
and I'm gonna run hyperfine again,
but inject
my new URL,
which is delivered over
TLS
for free.
All those things don't look as good. However,
Fairmount Cloud is hosted in US East 1
and I am in Europe. So the latency
at minimum is probably gonna be about three
hundred millisecond.
But we had 10 requests to the remote
server that responded
and just to show this
oh, I copied that by mistake.
Just to show you the headers here
on the response.
There's why it's so slow.
Let's try it IPv6 first. So let's do
that again
with dash four.
Yeah. Much faster.
And we get
redirect to get hub Rawkode Academy. So
lots of really cool things here.
Spend build, edit code, spend build, spend up
for local development, spend deploy, throw it to
Fermion Cloud for free, get TLS, get custom
domain names, all this other cool stuff. I'm
gonna be doing a lot more with this
entire platform because I really wanna push this
URL shortener to do my own bedding
rather
than Ryan on relying on services with Bitly.
And another really cool idea I've got is
I wanna build my own analytics engine, like
Google Analytics, but using just WebAssembly
and request. Because I reckon we could do
some pretty neat stuff in the browser and
on the server get a really key piece
of analytic experience. And I'm gonna push that
as far as I can go.
I'm gonna jump back to monologue phase,
check for any questions, but I hope you
like what you've seen and hopefully
your interest is peaked and you can check
out Spin and WebAssembly.
You got a question from Moz. Does Rust
follow TypeScript syntax?
They have some similarities for sure.
They're both modern languages that have learned a
lot. They provide strict typing.
They have functional constructs,
you know, the ability to map, reduce, etcetera.
They have error handling. So there's a lot
of things that are very similar. But I'd
say the Rust syntax is more esoteric.
TypeScript is a lot more familiar to people.
Coming from Caesar relative languages and JavaScript, it'll
feel very
yeah. Or even Java, it will feel good
and easy to understand. TypeScript,
with procedural macros
the unwrapping of everything and lifetimes
takes a little bit more effort. But if
you see similarities with TypeScript, that's good. Don't
let the scary stuff scare you away.
So Russell said,
so was it created a new connection for
each request? I got a phone call so
missed them in the video and still responding
in only twenty five milliseconds.
Yeah. The span run time only launches the
wasm binary when a request comes in that
matches the endpoint,
the route that you have it configured to.
Everything that you're seeing is the spend run
time, the fermion platform, which is also open
source by the way. You can go to
fermion.
Github.com/fermion.
You'll find the platform open source repository. You
can run it yourself on a EC two
instance on Equinix metal or GCP, whatever you
want. Pass it some WASM files and away
it goes. And so, yeah, you're getting a
unique instance of that web that web assembly
application for every request
or every Redis message within the cluster.
Cool.
Alright.
It looks like there are no more questions.
Thank you for joining me today. As I
said, I'll be doing a lot more with
WebAssembly,
and make sure you tune in for the
next episode. Thank you again. Have a wonderful
evening.